[Musik]
hallo Leute Ich ist wieder eure malwande
und willkommen bei einem Video bei dem
ich noch überhaupt nicht weiß was hier
passiert ich möchte ein Video drehen
aber ich habe die ganze Zeit kein Thema
bzw habe ich Themen aber die Themen sind
so voll und groß und viel und ich habe
keine Ahnung irgendwie feht mir die
Motivation Motivation die Motivation mti
fehlt mir mir fehlt die Motivation
irgendwas zu machen also generell aber
mehr so auf Youtube Videos bezogen
und ich stresse mich die ganze Zeit so
weil ich schon so wieder seit 10 Tagen
nichts hochgeladen habe und denke mir ja
komm alle großen Youtuber die laden alle
drei Tage was hoch und siehst du doch
die werden immer größer das bringt was
und ich möchte das auch weil ich gerne
mir regelmäßig contonent angucke den ich
mir gerne anschaue also sofern ihr euch
das gerne anschaut aber es funktioniert
halt nicht so und ich frage mich warum
warum das nicht funktioniert warum kann
ich nicht einfach meinen Kopf
einschalten und diese Videos die ich
jetzt da habe so drehen z.B möchte ich
Euch erzählen dass ich mich jetzt
vegetarisch ernähere Daumen nach oben
aber ich möchte kein ganzes Video davon
machen aber ich will auch nicht nur ein
Tweet machen ich möchte das schon
verkünden und jetzt sage ich euch das
ich werde mich ab sofort vegetarisch
ernähren und nicht weil ich so ein super
Tiermensch bin aber weil man einfach
nicht hinter dieser ganzen
Massentierhaltung stehen kann anderes
Thema ich möchte über reden ich möchte
euch sagen dass die AFD schlecht ist
aber we mehr als das kann ich irgendwie
auch nicht sagen ihr alle da draußen
wisst warum die AFD schlecht ist und ihr
alle da draußen wisst dass man die AFD
nicht wählen sollte denn wir hatten das
schon mal und wir haben genau dieses
Szenario schon wieder und jetzt wenn ich
das sage sage ich jetzt zu euch ein dass
ihr Hitler seid wenn ihr die AFD wählt
seid ihr das ich weiß es nicht ich weiß
nur dass sie schlecht ist ja und
irgendwie möchte ich euch auch
vermitteln dass ich ein Top trage und
mich eigentlich zu dick für ein Top
finde allgemein finde ich mich zu dick
ich habe zu dicken Bauch zu dicke Beine
zu dicke Arme ein zu dickes Gesicht und
eigentlich weiß ich dass ich gar nicht
zu dick bin aber was für ein Video soll
ich daraus machen Hallo Leute ich bin
dick aber eigentlich nicht wir sehen uns
alle falsch in unserem Weltbild und wir
sehen uns alle nicht so wie wir wirklich
sind und wir sollten auf innere Werte
achten was wir eh schon alle tun aber
irgendwie kommt das optische da immer
noch mit dazu und ich krieg keine Luft
ich habe ein Locher der sechs Löcher
macht ist das ein Video Wert ich möchte
euch erzählen wie gerne ich polarid
Fotos mag
[Musik]
ach so man darf polaroidbilder nicht
schütteln das dachten sie früher das
verwischt irgendwie nur die Farbe man
soll
warten ich habe meine Katzen gemalt und
das sieht richtig scheiße
aus trotzdem mag ich das Bild irgendwie
ich besitze Schilder auf den ich
verschiedene münde
habe ich habe nicht nur eine Schwäche
für Katzen sondern auch für Katzen
Sticker meine beste Freundin heißt Annie
und studiert den Kiel auf dem Bild sieht
man Anni und mich und da sind wir sehr
betrunken ich bin ein Messi ich sammel
Geschenktüten burgerverpackungen und
Schuhkartons nur damit ich sie
irgendwann zum Basteln verwenden kann
aber ich bastel fast nie was damit ich
würde mein Geld lieber in ein schönes zu
Hause reinpacken als in viele Reisen das
gebe ich aber nur selten zu weil die
Leute lieber sich Landkarten auf die
Körper tätowieren und damit sagen wollen
dass sie sehr viel Fernweh haben was ich
nicht habe ich möchte ein paar Sachen
sehen ich würde gerne mal nach England
und Polen war ich
schon ja diese Lampe habe ich mal
betrunken mit 16 von einer Baustelle
gestohlen es tut mir leid liebe
Baustelle wenn ihr sie wieder haben
wollt sie funktioniert eh nicht mehr
eines meiner Vorsätze für 2016 war
weniger Vorurteile zu haben ich gehöre
zu den Menschen die sehr schnell
urteilen und sich irgendwie Distanzieren
von Menschen die sie glauben nicht zu
mögen aber ich werde so oft vom
Gegenteil überzeugt dass ich mich
mittlerweile dazu entschlossen habe frei
in die Welt zu gehen und immer zu sagen
hey wer bist du ich habe zwar schon ein
Urteil aber das wird
sicher noch nicht bestätigt manchmal
frage ich mich wie gesund es für die
Psyche ist dass wir Youtuber Youtube
Videos machen wenn dann die Leute
schreiben mach mal mehr Videos dann
fühle ich mich einerseits geehrt und
denke ja ich will auf jeden Fall mehr
Videos machen andererseits kriege ich
dann mega Panik weil wenn ich diesen
wsch erfülle heißt es dann dass die
Person mich deabonnieren wird heißt es
dass irgendwann die Leute sich nicht
mehr für mich interessieren
werden wenn sich meine Katzen irgendwann
nicht mehr für mich interessieren man
weiß es nicht das Leben stckt so voller
Überraschung und wer weiß was wir alles
noch in 100 Jahren machen weil so alt
werden wir alle ich werde mindestens
122 bin ich 22 ich bin 22 dieses Jahr
werde ich 23 ein schönes
Alter
heute ist echt ein
Scheißtag tschüss